sortir
Michel
elle va déballer comme un toboggan
ça va papa regarde j'ai perdu ma
dentelle va te donner un euro
non un billet c'est trop mon cœur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez tous cliqué et oui vous avez
vu première fois avec ma meuf vous êtes
dit tiens il va nous raconter sa
première dune à moi et sa meuf et non
c'est encore un petit titre racoleur ah
ça a marché parce que c'est la première
fois qu'on tourne ensemble et oui alors
il faut faire un vœu
ne me lâche plus elle est venue danser
sur le parquet de Danse avec les stars
salut tout le monde sait qu'elle existe
toujours la vidéo sur moi pas trop
qu'elle prenne trop de place en bas
[Musique]
alors je n'avais jamais vu ça il y a une
piscine à neige
où tu peux vraiment prendre une douche
de neige
apparemment ça va fermer mais gros pour
l'essayer faudra juste se contenter de
dire ok ça va